sally turning our attention to breaking
news tonight a homicide in the northeast
valley
marks the fifth murder in las vegas this
weekend
the latest happened near lamb and las
vegas boulevard orca mana just spoke
with metro police and he joins us
with live with the latest on this orco
sasha a violent weekend across the las
vegas valley metro police
say this latest incident that they're
investigating right now
is a deadly stabbing that happened just
outside the
taco shop back there detectives tell us
a homeless man in his late 20's
walked into the business around 8
o'clock tonight asking for money and
food
the owner asked him to leave and there
was some kind of a disturbance
when one of the employees described as a
man in his early 30s
escorted the homeless man out into the
parking lot they got into a fight that's
when the homeless man pulled out a knife
and stabbed the employee in the chest he
was taken to umc where he died
police say this isn't the first time the
suspect has caused issues here
apparently the homeless male who entered
the business the suspect has been a
continual problem in the area
so when he entered they immediately
asked him to leave and that's what
prompted them to escort him outside
metro tells us the homeless man walked
away from the business but was found by
responding patrol officers
still holding the knife he was taken
into custody but is that but
is at the hospital tonight due to a
couple stab wounds to his arm which
police say might be self-inflicted
we're told once he's released he'll be
booked for one count
of open murder that's the latest here
tonight reporting live in the northeast
valley orca mana 8 news now